stéfane marion bonsoir soir la hausse
des taux d'intérêt aux etats-unis le
plus haute la plus forte hausse en trois
décennies est ce que c'est un coup de
barre pour vous qui était totalement
justifiée j'ai calé la dernière fois que
ça s'est passé donc j'étais prêt à la
banque nationale mais j'étais à l'heure
pour témoigner qu'est ce que ça fait 75
points de base je voudrais qu'il ya un
phénomène de rattrapage monsieur fillon
le les banques centrales après avoir
traîné la patte trop longtemps doivent
être mon de rattapage les bouches et
donc seront à des bouchées doubles pour
justement l'ennemi numéro un qu'on doit
combattre maintenant c'est l'inflation
pour permettre à voir des plans
d'affaires plus facile à établir dans le
temps on doit on doit essayer de juguler
l'inflation est ce que la banque
fédérale et en rattrapage justement
parce qu'elle a raté raté son évaluation
de l'inflation moi je pense qu'une
mission de droite erreurs de politique
monétaire ont attendu trop longtemps
pierron canada aussi en passant mais
malgré la hausse de 75 points de base on
n'est pas encore un territoire
restrictif donc une perspective de
croissance économique qui demeure au
rendez vous alors quand 94 on en avait
des niveaux beaucoup plus élevés donc je
pense et la nuance importante ce
phénomène de rattrapage est ce qu'on se
dirige vers une politique monétaire
restrictive peut-être post année on
verra s'ils peuvent atteindre les
objectifs qu'ils se sont fixés
aujourd'hui est ce que on comprend quand
même qu'il y aura d'autres hausse de 75
points de base
on verra s'il peut faire 75 peut-être le
prochain oui après ça je crois qu'on
devrait se calmer parce qu'une chose est
évidente on a déjà un impact important
sur la confiance des consommateurs aux
états unis ce qui laisse présager un
ralentissement dès cet été aux états
unis donc pour enrayer l'inflation faut
commencer avec un ralentissement
économique et je pense que ça pourrait
se produire dès cet été de là
les atteintes de 4% de comme la réserve
fédérale nous annonce aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de nuances apportées monsieur
fillon je pense qu'on ira au dessus
d'eux et demi on ira peut-être à 3 après
ça ça devient beaucoup plus nuancée le
taux directeur à 1,5 1,75
on nous dit jusqu'à trois et demi à la
fin de l'année vous pensez qu'on
dépassera peut-être pas trois parce que
la fed devrait voir un peu essayé de
voir ce que ça ce que ça veut dire dans
l'économie réelle pression d'action a
absolument que vous savez lorsqu'on page
dommages collatéraux sont pas uniques
aux états unis.le les dommages
collatéraux de la hausse des taux aux
etats-unis vont se faire sentir au
niveau planétaire donc lancement
planétaire qui pourrait entraîner une
réduction de la demande pour le prix des
denrées dans les prochains mois puis
aussi ce sans compter la rouverture
potentiel de la chine qui pourrait
amener aussi une baisse de l'inflation
donc encore une fois beaucoup
d'incertitudes on va aller à 3%
au-dessus de ça c'est beaucoup moins
évident est ce qu'on s'en va donc en
récession ou quels sont les niveaux de
risque de récession aux états unis moi
je pense qu'à 4% ce les risques seraient
plus élevés mais si à 3% ou à 12 me pour
ça on voit déjà c'était un
ralentissement économique le
ralentissement économique qui entraîne
une réduction de la cadence des
embauches va entraîner une réduction de
l'inflation donc encore une fois
phénomène de rattrapage la politique
monétaire n'est pas restrictive donc je
pense effectivement que le scénario de
récession est peu trop tôt que ça
devienne le scénario de base aux états
unis aux états unis on aura là données
sur l'inflation au canada la semaine
prochaine la dernière lecture qu'on a eu
ses 6,8 est ce qu'on saura 7% selon veut
avec le taux de chômage qui est arrivé
depuis 1974 est fort à parier que
l'inflation canada demeure vigoureuse
aussi ce mois ci ce qui va probablement
entraîner une hausse des taux d'intérêts
reprend la même cadence qu aux etats
unis aujourd'hui le mois prochain est ce
que la banque du canada le 13 juillet
augmente de 75 points je pense que oui
étant donnée la résilience de l'économie
canadienne faut pas oublier qu'on est qu
une économie qui bénéficie
l'augmentation du prix des denrées en
général ce la raison pour laquelle nous
avons le pib nominal le plus vigoureux
du pays du g7 je pense que oui ils sont
justifiés d'y aller avec 75 points quels
sont les risques de récession alors au
canada ben dans un contexte où la
politique monétaire américaine ne tombe
pas en reste très trop restrictif
je pense pas que la bande que l'oeuvre
non plus vouloir amener des mises à pied
donc je pense que le scénario de base
c'est un ralentissement économique et la
récession demeure un scénario alternatif
moment on se parle monsieur girard
évalue à 35 % les risques de récession
monsieur legault évalue même jusqu'à 50%
qu'est-ce que vous emparez vous me
pardonnerez choisir le camp d'un
économiste un comptable c'est pas payée
pour faire des prévisions économiques
donc j'y vais avec l'économiste la
ministre des finances
le comptable et à monsieur legault la
comptable est un premier ministre et
hall premier ministre donc comme une
surenchère entre monsieur girard et
monsieur legault aujourd'hui surtout que
c'est un ancien de la banque nationale
eric girard en plus mais c'est un
économiste c'est un économiste donc il y
risque sont évalués donc à 35% vous
trouvez ce raisonnable donc comme
évaluation des risques de récession au
québec je pense que dans le contexte
actuel absolument qu'ils ont pu oublier
que encore une fois l'économie
canadienne son marché de l'emploi est
vigoureuse contre ans que les
ralentissements au niveau de
l'immobilier qui va se faire sentir au
cours des prochains mois mais la
profitabilité des entreprises suger qui
aura pas de mises à pied sévère au cours
des prochains mois puis dans ce contexte
là je pense une croissance autour de 2%
ok dernier point la bourse ont réagi
très positivement cet après-midi parce
que de message est très clair de la
réserve fédérale
par rapport à son action voilà on va
prendre à bras le corps l'inflation
comment vous l'interprétez mais
dignement ce là dedans parce que
monsieur par la main de dieu il y aura
des dommages collatéraux en même temps
je veux pas de bases non plus je pas de
pertes d'emplois donc vous comprenez
pour la vo soit ok on avait 10 4% mais
peut-être que tu n'iras pas à 4% donc
encore une fois c'est un scénario
économique qui très difficile à
modéliser étant donnée la pandémie qui
est toujours en cours aussi le choc
d'offre énergie aliments la guerre donc
on peut pas calibré les modèles aussi
facilement qu'auparavant donc je pense
que dans ce contexte les marchés se dit
mot qu'il ya peut-être un petit peu plus
de certitudes dans son scénario même
s'il dit qu'il va là 4% ce qui prouve
même y aller donc je pense qu'on verra
pour la bourse au cours des prochains
une semaine mais il semblait y avoir eu
dix nuance c'est sage merci stéphane
marion plaisait beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]